in the last video in order to in order
to evaluate this indefinite integral we
first made the substitution that X is
equal to 3 sine theta and then this got
us to an integral of this form then we
were able to break up these sines and
cosines and use a little bit of our trig
identities to get it into the form where
we could do use substitution we did
another substitution where we set that U
is equal to cosine of theta and then
finally we were able to get it into a
form using that second round of
substitution and this time it was u
substitution we were able to get in to
form that we could actually take the
antiderivative and we got the final
answer here in terms of U but now we got
to go and undo everything we have to
undo the substitutions so the first
substitution that or the last
substitution we had done we're not going
to go in reverse order was that u was
equal to cosine theta so you might just
want to you might just want to
substitute U with cosine theta here but
then we're going to have everything in
terms of cosine theta which still
doesn't get us to X so the ideal is if I
can somehow Express u in terms of X so
let's think how we can do it we know
that U is equal to cosine theta we know
the relationship between X and theta is
right over here X is equal to 3 sine
theta so let's write that over here so
we know that X right over here we know
that X X is X is equal to 3 3 sine theta
so if we could somehow write cosine let
me rewrite this a little bit differently
or we could also say that X over 3 is
equal to sine theta I just divided both
sides by 3
so if we could somehow reexpress this in
terms of sine theta then we can replace
all the sine Thetas with x over 3 s and
we are done
so how can we do that and actually show
you two techniques for doing it so the
first one is to make the realization
okay U is equal to cosine of theta if I
want to write this in terms of sine of
theta I can just say that this is equal
to straight-up this is the most
fundamental trigonometric identity this
is cosine theta is 1 minus the square or
the square root of 1 minus sine squared
theta and we see sine of theta is equal
to x over 3 so this is the square root
of 1 minus 1 minus x over 3 1 minus x
over 3 squared so u this is U in terms
of
X so everywhere we see a you up here we
can replace it with this expression and
we are essentially done we would have
written this in terms of X now there's
another technique you might sometimes
see in a calculus class where someone
says okay we know that U is equal to
cosine theta we know this relationship
how can we express u in terms of X and
we'll just say let's draw a right
triangle they'll draw a right triangle
like this I'll draw a right triangle and
they'll say okay look sine of theta is x
over three so if we say that this is
theta right over here sine of theta is
the same thing as opposite over
hypotenuse opposite over hypotenuse is
equal to x over three so let's say that
this is X and then this right over here
is three then the sine of theta will be
x over three so we look at that first
substitution right over here but in
order to figure out what U is in terms
of X we need to figure out what cosine
of theta is well cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse so we have to figure out what
this adjacent side is well we could just
use the Pythagorean theorem for that
Pythagorean theorem would tell us that
this is going to be the square root of
the hypotenuse squared which is nine
minus the other side squared minus x
squared so from this we fully kind of
solved the right triangle in terms of X
we can realize that cosine of theta is
going to be equal to the adjacent side
square root of nine minus x squared over
the hypotenuse over three which is the
same thing as 1/3 times the square root
of 9 minus x squared which is the same
thing if we square one-third and put it
into the radical so we're essentially
going to take the what the square
one-third is the same thing as the
square root of 1/9 so this is going to
we can rewrite this as the square root
of 1/9 times 9 minus x squared
essentially just brought the 1/3 into
the radical now it's 1/9 and so now this
is going to be the same thing as the
square root of 1 1 minus x squared 1
minus x squared over 9 which is exactly
this thing right over here x squared
over 9 is the same thing as x over 3
squared so either way you get the same
result I find using the trig identity
right over here to express cosine of
theta in terms of sine theta and then
just do this substitution
to be a little bit more straightforward
but now we can just substitute into the
original thing so either of these I can
write it as either way this thing right
over here this is the same thing as 1
minus x squared over 9 to the 1/2 power
that's what u is equal to and we
everywhere we see you we just substitute
it with this thing so our final answer
in terms of X is going to be equal to
243 times U to the fifth this to the
fifth power over 5 this to the fifth
power is 1 minus x squared over 9 it was
to the 1/2 but if we raise it to the
fifth power stop I'm going to be to the
5 1/2 power over 5 over 5 minus this to
the this to the 3rd power 1 minus x
squared over 9 to the three-halves
racing this to the 3rd power that's this
right over here over 3 and then all of
that plus C and we're done it's messy
but using first trig substitution then
use substitution or trig substitution
then rearranging using a couple of our
techniques for manipulating these powers
of trig functions we're able to get into
a form of record use u substitution and
then we were able to unwind all the
substitutions and actually get evaluate
the indefinite integral